ray Ratto of the CSM bay area joining us
here as we are at op Levi's Stadium
right now
prior to rams 49ers how are you Ray I'm
having the time of your life you love
Thursday night football don't you Ray
like deep down though deep down I wish
the games had more more compelling
matchups just like this one I mean this
is the game that basically made soccer
the the fastest-growing sport in America
well the problem here's the problem with
Thursday Night Football ray is that
everybody's got to play on it it's like
the orange wedge in speaking of soccer
in an AYSO
everybody gets one because of the
competitive the competitive issue of the
short weeks that you cannot have
multiple Thursday's on your schedule
with the exception of Washington and and
Dallas that will play the week after
Thanksgiving and on which they both play
so they get a full complement of of time
off for a regular week and also the
Chiefs
and the Patriots because they played the
first Thursday of the season other than
that so there really is no fix to that
no I think there really isn't but on the
other hand that doesn't concern me if
the National Football League wants to
start sending me regular checks to be
worried about this I will catch them
with glee so let's work let's talk about
the teams that you do cover the 49ers
are still looking for their first
touchdown this year all that said hey is
there a palpable culture change that you
can field with the Lynch Shanahan era
starting right um I I think that's
incredibly premature I mean you've got
to be on the you've got to be on the job
more than 120 minutes of football it
seems to me to provide the kind of
evidence of culture change that I think
you're asking about and and I think when
you've got a an ocean liner that's run
aground you don't get back out to seve
quickly quick I would imagine that
you'll find out every
you need to know about Kyle Shanahan and
John Lynch in about two years
but I think it's going to take that long
because this was a team that had
bottomed out last year in spectacularly
bad fashion so there's so many things
they have to fix and since they're both
new they will make mistakes along the
line that new guys always make and until
that you know until they figure out what
to do and what not to do and how to do
it and how not to do it I think they'll
probably look a lot like they did last
year for a while it's just the nature of
things you just you know you can't you
can't hit the ground running in an
industry this complicated it just seems
to me so you know we talk up much about
how the Jets are going to tank Ford
Arnold or Rosen and and there will be
other teams that will be in that mix as
the season progresses what is the 49ers
plan at quarterback as you can tell any
place for the Washington Redskins I
think that is plan a plan B is CJ
Beathard Plan C is Brian Hoyer and plan
D is despair weeping
let's talk might be a little bit you
think we see CJ Beathard at any point
soon I only think you see CJ Beathard if
a Hoyer gets hurt or is so awful that he
is deemed unwatchable or B they don't
think they can get cousins or they cool
on cousins because I think the idea
behind Hoyer was that he would be the
bridge to the next guy and I don't think
they thought CJ Beathard was going to be
that when camp started and I don't think
they are so in love with him that they
have radically changed their view I
think he is not the heir apparent if
they think they can get Kirk Cousins to
come West and I don't believe they're
going to lose enough games to be in the
d'arnot sweepstakes so I think you're
only going to see him in case of either
emergency
complete abandonment or fear that they
aren't going to get cousins or that they
don't want him so I mean that that's a
convoluted way of answering they'd
rather not have to see them but if they
have to it will be because they did
something fundamental has changed
NBC Sports Bay Area senior insider ray
rata joining me here on the Rich Eisen
show so based on this the future desired
quarterback of the San Francisco 49ers
is taking on the Oakland Raiders on
Sunday Night Football this weekend and
Ray I just don't think enough people are
talking about that the the Raiders move
and relocation is so unique we will
never see another situation where the
first home game of a team that has
announced its intention to relocate in a
couple of years that has no protests no
people freaking out no people's not
showing and instead there's a favored
son returning to the sport on behalf of
the town dancing on the sidelines like
Marshawn Lynch we will never see this is
like the the all-time happiest
relocation I've ever heard of um first
of all because it's being done in
glacial time the panic hasn't set in yet
in addition because Marc Davis so
aggressively sought other homes even
before he got this one they've had about
four years to go through whatever the
mourning process is they've known all
along that Oakland was not in a
financial position to build them
anything nor was Oakland in a mood to
try to match economic wits with the
National Football League so I think for
a lot of people this is already a fait
accompli and in the Bay Area I think
almost more than any other place when
you've lost a team when when you've
decided you've had enough you don't go
to the games and boo you stay home and
you just go I
other stuff to do they're more willing
they're more willing to walk on a team
then I think a lot of fan bases are just
because they get from this is the most
important thing in my life to screw it
I'll go I'll go sail on the bay in about
40 seconds so I think I think a lot of
people have already begun the transition
I mean don't forget mark Davis was
flirting with San Antonio three years
ago and then he played really hard to
get LA and that's I mean that's eighteen
months back so it's been at least three
years and not not if not more that
they've known he wanted to go so they've
had time to prep this well it's also
helpful that that there they may just
wind up being the best team in the
National Football League to I mean they
what yeah I see I think that's where the
angst is I think it it this is not a
perfect analogy but it's a little bit
like what Quebec Nordiques fans would
have felt like had they known their team
was going to leave just as it became a
Stanley Cup contender because as soon as
they left Quebec and went to Denver they
want a cup right away and that thinks
then that still stings in that community
and I think Raider fans want a Super
Bowl before their team leaves and I
think that's where the angst really is
it's just they know that the window
right now is as open as it's been in
decades and they would they would like
to get one before the team goes and they
know that it's going to be three years
at the outside and ran so that's not a
huge window but it's bigger than a lot
of teams have a couple more minutes with
Ray Ratto
NBC Sports Bay Area insider senior
insider pardon me I want to lose the
senior have they turned us a shovel in
Vegas yet for this stadium they have not
so because the Raiders and UNLV are in a
bit of a squabble about how the stadium
is going to be shared because it has to
be shared by virtue of the way the
Raiders got the money but everything I
have heard for
both sides is that the shovel goes on
the ground in November which still gives
them a fighting chance of being there by
nineteen although not much of a chance
okay they wait much longer than January
they might need another two years in
Auckland beyond the two they already are
planning on it
Wow Wow last one for you Rea is how is
the Kevin Durant fake social media
account if it did exist or not how did
this whole Twitter Instagram thing play
out and not only with the fans here but
also with the Warriors front office best
you could tell um well the Warriors
front office didn't get very involved
with it because their position is pretty
much to treat adults like adults even
when they do foray into adolescence and
I mean it wasn't it wasn't a legal issue
so they didn't really have to put a
lawyer on it it's I I think they
recognized that kept with Kevin Durant
slights run deep and they're there I'm
sure they have told him look you've got
to let this you know roll off your back
at some point I mean you won you know
it's sort of like the lottery winner
complaining that he has to drive to the
lottery office to pick up the money it's
I think they just sort of view it as
Kevin's little cork which is that
Oklahoma City is always going to be a
little bone spur forever you know it's
he's not going to be able to let it go
it's just going to have to diminish with
time and rings then rings that's because
I mean in all other ways he not only
made the smart move he made he made a
phenomenal move he got a jewelry he got
a parade he got business contacts in
Silicon Valley next year he's going to
get a supermax deal I mean where's wish
the downfall here you know I mean if you
want to sit and wash yourself in guilt
you know go sign with Brooklyn
[Music]
rare I love this man thanks for calling
in I hope to of hope to see you tonight
oh I'm sure that that will pass
thank you Ray that's Ray rattle the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
radio stations across the country and
audience if you like that please
download our app there's lots of fun
things there other than just more of the
videos you just saw you can call us from
the app you can email us from the app
just download it trust me you'll enjoy